elle à nouveau en deuxième partie de
l'effet des maths
donc aujourd'hui fait c'est un truc un
peu rien à voir avec la dernière fois et
c'est un paquet de reçus hier sur lequel
déjà été impliqué récemment et on a déjà
des trucs mais pas très content avec ce
qu'on a pour l'instant
et du coup aussi de faire mieux donc
encore une fois c'est pas si vous êtes
là pour comprendre ce que je fais ça va
être un petit peu compliqué parce que je
vais pas expliquer du tout tout ce que
je fais je n'aime pas être forcées voir
à l'écran b asus pour ceux qui veulent
les pieds en train de réfléchir voir
exploiter la folie byzantine email bon
c'est un problème encore compliqué alors
quelques notations je fais mon petit pas
mais tertiaire et du coup des boulons
terreur
son humour coeur ok donc dans une tête
et at&t a qui regardent et auquel vous
avez à mettre ensuite
ok donc ensuite
ensuite on a comme moi ce que je
pourrais appeler des sous-ensembles des
serveurs directement par le métal sans
leur hockey ensuite on a donc trois ans
semble aléatoire avoir par son énorme et
donc on a x djl femmes
[Musique]
l'étrange us qu ils n'ont pas pas faire
ça
ok s alpher bonjour les distances elle
sous x tu regardes fédérer notation s
comme serveur x svw weekes a dépendu
worker donc le worker reçoit un
sous-ensemble de l'ensemble des
décideurs
est ce qu on va avoir ensuite une
communication
alex a
w vrs semble un choix et on va voir
l'ensemble x à des sps enfin lors de la
flèche est wwf
[Musique]
lorna s sas instance d'angers 2-1 c'est
ce week-end que ça veut dire que dans
chaque étape
d'abord des serveurs on voit à chaque
worker un ensemble fin de leurs
paramètres il ya seulement un seul
instant qu'il reçoit ok c'est bon hockey
et on va appeler aussi une fonction
générale
z a une fonction z
je peux changer de style ou fonctions en
z tsw alpha qui me prend xds w qui va
être la tacc salle était donc
s'attaquent eux
voilà donc la tacc ressemble à ça parce
que pour ce cas la suite aux attaques il
habitait à ew sxs et enfin la dss xts
presse au caire
donc ok ok donc on va dans supposer que
à chaque étape on a donc un vecteur tat
utilisé c'est qu'on a des tas ttt va
être envoyé aux différents worker qui
vont du coup calculer et ouais je peux
être l'hôte est épaté est-ce pour
serveurs ensuite on a un tat w pour
chaque workers qui est égal à l'ensemble
des têtes at et alpha d'état t alpha
donc save est ce qu'on va prendre je
baissais repli sa gare au gorille en
tout cas du coup qui va dépendre de
l'ensemble tu va dépendre de valeur de
téte ats de l'ensemble des trucs qui
vous des poulets donc c'est celui-là xds
w alpha et qui va dépendre de l'ensemble
des attaques pour alpha du coup that et
sw alpha qu'est ce que je peux être au
même niveau notation à ce que je peut
simplifier notation on se penche pas mal
parce que notation plus jolie c'est un
peu lourd mais moi voyais aller avec ça
ok donc ensuite à partir de ça a beau
être menée dans tous les sens ok mais
ensuite ça on estime suite des gradients
donc ça va être
gwt qui va des ponts qui va dépendre
ouais c'est ça donc c'est le gradient je
peux appeler rappelé un gradient de l au
point des dates et w et je vais prendre
ça par rapport à des variables
aléatoires cité et doubla ensuite
que se passe-t-il après ça c'est
gradient suite sont envoyés ok la lie en
envoya serveurs worker là c'est juste ou
encore compétition ensuite sitruk par
contre sont envoyés des worker aux
serveurs et les worker eux
qu'est ce qu'ils font lyon va aux
serveurs surtout qu'est-ce que le
serveur reçoit donc c'est là qu'il ya à
nouveau une possibilité d' attaque et
donc chaque serveur lui va recevoir
je vais l'appeler j'ai minuscule
toujours est de thé qui va être du coup
l'ensemble des jets à paix qui sont
alors montés donc rester car aux dires
macarons cars 2 de l'ensemble des gwt
avec cette fois ceux qui ont été reçus
par les différentes personnes x1 tws
hockey et il y a aussi les attaques donc
z tws à
voilà donc que c'est pour et appartenant
à hs et l'eau c'est pour les alfa
appartenant à doubler sa lettre la
tunisie pour y boire coeur dans
l'étreinte insu pour les serveurs et
être great wall évoqué ensuite donc une
passe de complications mais cette fois
du côté serveur compétition très simple
ça va nous donner tes tard moi je peux
l'appeler sa tête a pu t + 1/2 à dire
dit athée plus saint denis s est égal à
d'état ts3 dit athée gts jeu plus est
les exportations tentatives et d'autres
notation qui était moins chouette hockey
et ensuite on a une communication de
serveur à serveur où chaque serveur va
ensuite garantir le fait qu' il va se
rapprocher des autres pour cela
ce qui va se passer c'est que tu es tu
as they come on les rapproche
répéta t puissant cette fois est ce ça
va être cette fois donc j'ai rater
voilà donc tu es tu à tes +1 à dives
être égal à 5.54 3 qui va être appliqué
à gtc non non je réfléchis plus je cette
mécanique mais ça marche pas alors
qu'est ce que je fais pour cela je
prends les trucs en 1/2 seat est un des
plus un demi s en fonction de ce qui m'a
été envoyé donc x1 des espèces et des
attaques des bisontins exedra tss
voilà ok c'est cool du tout car que ce
matin oui pour répandre un peu je
passais des questions donc donc savoir
le plat le problème c'est de faire de
très rapidement donc c'est de faire de
l'apprentissage sur des machines mais
dans un système où il ya la fois
plusieurs serveurs et plusieurs workers
who works heures avons essayé d'aider
les serveurs à améliorer leurs
paramètres les par les serveurs aussi
des millions de leurs paramètres et le
truc c'est qu'il faut que les
communications entre les deux à la fois
pour que les worker savent quels sont
les paroles des serveurs pour ensuite
faire mise à jour par rapport à ces
paramètres qui s'appelle la descente de
gradient stochastique et a besoin de
savoir où est ce qu'on aime et ensuite
avoir envoyé des messages à des serveurs
et les serveurs us feront leur mise à
jour et ils vont aussi d'essayer de se
coordonner pour avoir à peu près les
mêmes paramètres et en fait c'est très
important
et la difficulté c'est de prouver que
tout ça va mieux a fonctionné même si
certains des serveurs et des walker peut
cracher peut ne plus répondre ou pire
peut être acquis c'est un peu le
problème recherche globale
on a fait pas mal avancé déjà dessus pas
plus tard que ce matin mais il faut
encore plus de travail pour faire un
truc vraiment très très clean
je pense qu'il a fait un truc bien mieux
que ce qu'on a fait en corse matin et
enfin beau c'est un petit peu donc c'est
un petit peu l'algorithme et ce sur quoi
on va bosser
bon ok qu'est ce que je remette anti
résumé plus plus court de penser de tout
ça alors on a du coup est ce qui peu
après une première communication d'état
twkr égal à k1 d'état tsx
et alors s'ils font parce le alpha sera
par wacker wcw zts wwf en suite on
envoie sein du ldd w si des preuves et
ensuite on nous ressort gps 10 du coût
42 g twx stw s7 et wss csa d'état t +
1/2 est il est athée et cela est à des
gts et ensuite on est athée +11 stegall
a qu'à 3 des tas d + 1/2 x s et espèce
et cette espèce
oups ça tient sur la ligne
[Applaudissements]
ok
ok donc qu'est ce qu'on a dit approuver
ce que c'est
[Musique]
définir mais bon ça savait que le
diamètre plus généralement donc à
définir le diamètre de téte à st et on
va mettre une norme pour une norme rvd
finir que le nex sur les extérieurs on a
dix mètres le team ab partenon richesse
de la norme rtt d'un thé à noter
ok ça c'est un diamètre en norme est
mais je vois aussi prendre notre truc
qui fait d'eux des communautés a ajouté
sa delta cw network et au psg c'est donc
ce pour y
quand même jusqu'à baie dumex sur les 1
[Musique]
pkp
c'était un peu notre tout petit et en
main en menant m'inquiète cycle normal
de critiquer normes
un tel taux de normes infinie petit et
des roses peut aussi être un tel pas
infinies petit jeu-là delta un
épileptique delta un petit cld et à cw
ensuite on m'a dit tu peux aller guetter
des normes un delta 1
elle est dictée et au canada
ok donc on était vraiment démontré on a
vu que delta cw est plus petit ne t'ai
tout xs bon silo classe pour tout décor
est plus qu'un demi sxs peer2me pour
toutes xe spss pour tous zfs espèce
telle tard cw peu
cac 4o est égal à nba m'étonnais c'est
ça
[Musique]
delta 2002 dans ces crimes hall pour 6,2
me paie deux états en 2000
[Musique]
le tit m acw et à 1/2 ps
passé sous l'hypothèse soit plus il faut
pour cela que le cardinal de x espèce
ouais donc ça il faut qu'ils contiennent
majorité de non byzantin
c'est à dire que son cardinal doit être
plus grand que q sur deux
c'est que ces affrontements prenne mon
cas moi j'adore ça s - s
qu est ce donc ça c'est cool
ce qu'on peut relever nos côtés ce qu'on
a fait là je pense appel à qu'il
implique que
ouais probabilité alors à trois quarts
allez on se met ça fait sale fait
directement résultera sait que
l'espérance tutelle tas de cw entre tsx
tcs sa espérant cela est fort plus un
mois creux bodian et w quelques mois en
espérant si la contraction ici ça
article qu'on a assez bien géré je pense
ce qu'il veut dire beaucoup plus que ça
est ce que c'est une bonne chose que
ceux ci étaient sous multiplicatif
vendetta cw oui oui mais qu'est ce que
vous la remplacez la médiane par autre
chose si on définit où on passe je vais
les finir
comment je m'appelais
bof milieu
ss miguel me tiens debout me dionne de
dts en demies xss ssss cette fois joué
le définir comme étant une moyenne donc
ça va être assez molle en deux retirez
nanda fois t'es tu as un demi plus un
new holland n'da fois le remède d'été tu
as fait un ami s7 est ce donc une
conjecture on veut faire une conjecture
ça serait que l'espérance terrassé w non
un domino sxs les aides sss
ça veut dire que ça ça va être plus
petit 1 - au lendemain d'un double vu ce
que c'est vrai ça sur youtube vous savez
si c'est vrai bon ok merci pour votre
avis
parce que ça c'est vrai donc
intuitivement gros london
même en mon mandat du contexte changeant
mon truc mais ici on donne intuitivement
il va voir alors il n'y a rien
d'affolant tel état et la poésie de
problème une comédie qui vient de
rentrer dans la salle lui dit vous
connaissez peut-être parce que c'est le
co auteur du livre le fabuleux chantier
on a train d'essayer de créer une boucle
infinie
bon en tout cas je pense qu'à un moment
je vais arrêter parce que merci d'avoir
empoisonné cette séance portant très
productive
des gens regardent rsa mais si ça
m'intéresse de voir mathématicien en
train de galérer sur son problème voilà
une prochaine